[Musik]
er hat es schon wieder getan als ob er
bekannt geworden als der französische
spiderman ist am mittwoch an der fassade
des vierthöchsten hochhauses in der
französischen hauptstadt paris
hochgeklettert über den 187 meter hohen
turm total brauchte der extremkletterer
etwas mehr als eine stunde
zahlreiche schaulustige sahen ihm
staunen zu in der vergangenheit hatte
robert dieses gebäude bereits zweimal
bezwungen daneben aber noch mehr als 150
beeindruckende hochhäuser in der ganzen
welt
er könne das klettern einfach nicht
lassen sagt robert für mich ist das
klettern eine leidenschaft es ist eine
art zu lieben
ich habe mit dem klettern im alter von
elf jahren angefangen ich werde bald 56
jahre und daran irgendwann mit dem
klettern aufzuhören denke ich überhaupt
nicht es sei denn ich bekomme eine sehr
ernste krankheit die mich davon abhält
sonst werde ich weitermachen nicht immer
dafür allerdings so wie er will
er klettert immer ohne erlaubnis und
wurde deswegen schon mehrfach verhaftet
das konnte ihn allerdings noch nicht
dazu bringen sich von den hochhäusern
fernzuhalten